it is time for drizzy news your daily
sighting of the majestic good news whale
right off the blow by your blowhole yeah
it was okay i got it well with me at the
desk is the best co-pilot in the
business rossi ross hi everybody
[Applause]
um
first up today in the headlines uh she
is a culinary icon
julia childs
julia oh yes and food and wine reports
that the food network is launching the
julia child challenge which is a
competition show where chefs will
recreate julia's classic recipes it's
literally going to be like a side by
side and it's all for a chance for the
prize to go to a french cooking school
take a look
they'll cook alongside their hero lulu's
really yummy who also started as a home
cook i just love to walk around in the
kitchen and found her calling later in
life welcome to the french chef i'm
junior child they'll cook in a kitchen
just like hers it's so close to the real
thing with the same ingredients that she
used that made her voila
i mean if this isn't appointment tv i
don't know what is it starts tonight on
the food network but wait there's more
if you need it because hbo max is
launching their unscripted series julia
about the visionary leap that she took
onto television in 1963 and it's
starring sarah lancashire
and david hyde pierce as julia's husband
paul
um
ross i know i can't i can i'll tell you
i love julia child for many reasons but
there's something about julia she uh she
made you feel like you could embrace the
mistakes in the kitchen and hello hi
rebel homemaker i mean i am a human
living walking breathing mistake yes
i'm all about the messing up also
there's something about her i relate to
i mean she sounded different she looked
different than everybody else on
television and that's why we fell in
love with her and there should be more
people that don't fit the mold
on television
i love that about it
you're so right rossi
one time i had breakfast with meryl
streep i swear to this hold on
i'm gonna need cpr real quick anyone
wanna i know and she i got there and she
was already there i was like of course
meryl beat me there like oh i should
have been waiting for her it's meryl
streep and i came in and she had her
script up and she was like yeah i'm just
doing learning this dialect for my next
character julia child
um and i was like
i think it's gonna be amazing yeah and
she was not my friend oscar ford if that
isn't like the go-to movie when it comes
across your scroll of your tv guide oh
my god every time i will dip in i can't
go past it no matter where i have to
watch it julia it's the greatest movie
amy adams stanley two cheats so julia
for everything well um meryl you were
amazing and julian julia i can't wait
for all this julia child love coming up
[Music]